monsieur poutine n'est pas dans la liste
des sanctionnés
mais alors qui en russie va prendre les
premiers coups de l'union européenne il
ya d'abord le secteur financier les 27
médecins à toutes leurs transactions
avec deux banques russes des banques
ayant contribué à financer les
opérations militaires dans le donbass ce
n'est pas une première des sanctions
visent déjà plusieurs établissements
bancaires depuis l'annexion de la crimée
en 2014 mais selon les experts l'impact
devrait être léger car ces banques sont
relativement mineurs d'autant que de
nombreux capitaux russes ont déjà été
rapatriés ces derniers jours
la russie ne pourra également plus se
fournir en argent auprès de créanciers
d'européens c'est une
vraie solidarité entre nous une vraie
solidarité à l'égard de l'ukraine une
vraie volonté commune une solidarité
entre les 27 mais aussi avec les
britanniques et les américains
impossible donc désormais pour moscou de
lever des fonds en euros en dollars et
en livres des marchés qui lui permettait
pourtant de refinancer sa dette
autre train de sanctions
les individus
nous imposerons aussi des sanctions aux
élites russes et aux membres de leur
famille des proches du président poutine
impliqué dans sa politique les sanctions
sont connus
gels d'avoirs et interdiction de visa
notamment pour les 351 députés de la
douma
et enfin dernière mais non des moindres
les sanctions énergétiques
un choix judicieux car le secteur
représente 80 % des recettes publiques
russes mais c'est aussi un pari risqué
pour les 27 qui importe 40% de leurs
besoins en gaz à la russie alors pour
taper du poing sur la table sans se
tirer une balle dans qu'est berlin en
concertation avec le reste de l'union a
gelé le projet gazier nord stream 2 qui
relie moscou à l'allemagne un projet qui
n'est pas encore en fonction
n'a pas épuisé d'un coup tout la
capacité que nous avons répondu en clair
si la situation s'envenime davantage
l'occident dit avoir d'autres sanctions
sous la table